こんにちははじめセットとまず一人しまうわけです
masaki さんはいお菓子知ってますか4
するんです賢いですね
を
ん
生えというわけです今こちらに有名なものを100個集めました
なんかパッと b は館内のあります基本的に多分子とが食べたことあるというか味は
ばカップだろうなっていう奴100種類集めてみました
だいたいわかる症ってこれ言ったら自国民言われたくて tto
これこれにカンタロそりゃ位
私を貸せ大好き芸人でございます評価世代好きなんで式を課すべきではないんですけど
も
お菓子の味を食べただけで歌詞の名称答え
れる
だと思います
おかしな顔力ですねなのでこちらに100円も歌詞があるんで今からで隠して貯めて
奴隷の味を堪えますさせに今はこれ全部何から買っても把握してないし名前も1個ずつ
覚えてないので何が来るかわからない状況で今からお菓子は100個入って100問中
何問正解できるかでお菓子マイスターのあー
ポイント書はないですねマイスターだったら車
一100いきますよじゃあ95といったらお菓子までたんだ逆に90までいかなかっ
たらかじゃねーか
もう自動車学校通いな刑部薄茶も散策食べていきましょう
えーっと10ルールとしては雑貨があってたらいいたいだけ食べたら
サティ感あるということででいきましょうでまぁ100もよろしくお願いしますじゃあ
ね
簡単目立って殺すかなこりゃ
れまず金造するなんか好きそうなやつから行くは最初はこれ行きまー
1個目
[音楽]
これ食べ好きだと思うあっ
完全今分ああ
んありこれいきます
[音楽]
なにこれなにこれなにこれあ初球でそれプリッツでしょ
やシャッターこうって言っ
怖いじゃないきまー
んですかチャンネルなんかな
キャラメルポップコーンでしょ待ってます
パッケージの説明していたなると赤いやつでしょどうぞそうかいいなんかあの辺が
名首振りのキャラか言ってる奴もうホンダんですあったらてるなんていうのはで
キャラメルコーン
あ
政府ギコリッターこれスキマー
[音楽]
まれっ
ブーブー s ピッ2種
パタ ren
これいっぱい食べるよねー
なにこの優しい味前なんて多い
本屋さんなにこれにゃーんってなにこれやってそんなわかりやすい
結婚はヶ月いいと思うジャスティック
違う
政府は今世界のサッポロポテトんっ
ブーヴロン sole まあちょっぴっニョッキキュッキュッにょんちゃんヌー
を she does 学校いたされているんですけどでしょ
まあそうだけど
ですねそんなに切りこれネーミングと区長選はどういう名前
たべっ子どうぶつあ
こういうのだ
ハバネロ
アン世界
待ってなんて言わなきゃだからマーブルチョコレートなぜか龍の口の下みたいな
みんこあれだったんところに切るねサー
まあ送っあとてらんねー
マイクポップコーンカーリーの
黒子自分のコンソールパンツのダブルが
5を総裁に応えてくればと前コーン
だから投げばみたいなんでしょふーん
言うとあれ所パパ量と指に年が引っかかってるあでダウンあの真っ赤のあの
輪っかのだからわざわざゲーみたいな毛だけはみたいな昔
何ですか名前を鉄鋼アポて来か
あなゲーゼミや乾杯車
ぷりんぐですでしょ
うん
j やらかしたかガー年
ブーバーでしょブーバーよねーっそんな気はしてたんだよ
ポッキーの一間
世界だったのかぶれーもんだこれ
[音楽]
だれあああれあのなんだ
薄い白いパッケージのここはなやつでしょ
違うここなかっあれじゃあコーヒーココアがなんかな茶色いあれでしょ
ここじゃないほうでしょ
待ったて一つもここは関係ないんじゃなんだかよなんですか
ココナッツサブレああ
これは6列のあーほんと滑る
うまい棒なぁ儲かるんだけど明太子ああああカッター付&ぶーあっている
全10敗あっあんたの形ではカーン
[音楽]
なんか張り付いちゃってるよこれにある梅しうめっとわかめのシートみたいなんです
アンテ深めるはないけど
ノリで乗り遊べないだろおっとっとでしょ
a 好まれコーンを
なにこれ混ぜこれわかりやすいかと思った
キャベツ太郎の仲間みたいなんですよやレザーの中まあ
ねぇ何コレなにコネ世界はうまい棒のたこ焼き味
見ていいいい
あれだがすっげーっ何を使った
だめだちょっとここまで来る止まりすぎとちょっとわかんなかった感覚がマカダミ屋も
アレだ
あのアンボンドチョコの上位互換ジョイ部感じゆったり可愛いワンコ
こういう音はんっ
まず杭世界ある4
はぁっはぁっはぁっ
カラームーつはこんなんじゃなかったから
って言うから本当に難しいこれこちらチップスってこんなに難しいわるって辛いよねで
も
コンソメじゃない
うん無理だよ浮かんだもん何か思い込んだいう世界は
から米著
here か厚木見せるとああああヌーチーズ n 4カーサー
あめぐみんまい棒のポップなる
ポップコーン機がたんじゃこのアポロ
[拍手]
ブロックだった
ブーブーって
前もなそこだぱぷりこだ
[音楽]
かぷりっぷアプリ戸建ポパイ登ったのナビ
つばめじゃああー
はっはっはそんな爆走する犯される
えっどんだけちゃうにゃん付今でしょ
をよ
3本あああの
雨でしょ連投するんですねいいですねもうだいぶ降ってきたぞ
チェルシーあれじゃないのは強い食べる
これはもうねぇ
あのなぜいいですか公安時間かかる洞窟ですかね
あーなんか潰してルミネでしょ中組と同じパッケージのすすめです
ron しリゾール
80 v e
してたねあんぱんぐアーリーワークぞん
ブラックブラックだ
[拍手]
ヨメレバ
[音楽]
海外のアレだあの
200何な園の愚民
わかんないけどせよわれん
あっはぁああ
たぶんどこでくださいはぁっはぁっはぁっ
もうさー
名越哲平じゃん
寸座浦ないんだよヤバイよそれファインあんああっ
デルデルデルデのさん何処なんでしょ
美味しい一度このしっかかるパシーン
圧巻頭みたいなよ
って白い袋です
クロレッツだ big があるん
アルフォートなんだ
なぜこれだけに幸あれだあの家歳以下のやつだ
バージえっ
なんかな
そんな不味いとか違いますそうすごい中じゃないん
[音楽]
このポリゴンの
噛み合う5組世界をずっとの白狼骨を配置あうっかあっあっああっ
いきますあ f
ええええええ
あのコンポタージュの袋のやつ
家ですかどうぞはい
yeah
低回数宮中5カ所にファイターを認定しまーす
me
うううう
ni
me
あっはぁ